[Music]
please Rihanna's workout session
interrupted by her 10-month-old son it
feels like motherhood yeah the singer
shares this clip of her little one
snuggling up to her pregnant belly with
the caption look who don't want Mommy to
work out it really feels Like A lot's
happening all at once no doubt her baby
boys basking in attention from Mom
amazing he's a happy baby as he waits
for the arrival of his little sibling
it's all an exciting Journey so far I'm
just taking it as it comes Riri
announced she was expecting baby number
two with boyfriend ASAP Rocky during her
epic Super Bowl halftime show
[Applause]
being a new mom nothing would have
gotten me out the house if it wasn't a
challenge like that and Rihanna credits
becoming a mama as inspiration for her
big stage return when you become a mom
there's something that just happens
where you feel like you could take on
the world you can do anything and the
Super Bowl is one of the biggest stages
in the world so
as scary as that was because I haven't
been on stage in seven years
there's something exhilarating about the
challenge of it all and it's important
for for me to do this this year it's
important for representation it's
important for
my son to see that
as the couple continues navigating
Parenthood they're discovering their
favorite parts of it all oh my God the
morning's just like seeing his morning
face and you know like seeing a baby
with like little bags and waking up and
they're just like startled they're
trying to figure out where they at is
the cutest is my favorite part of the
day the mornings that's like I cherish
that what are you enjoying about this
journey with three right now everything
about it yeah I'm loving it I'm just
excited for what I don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so you know
I'm excited while they await their
newest edition the two are sure to
expect more moments like this
[Music]
please it's a long nine or ten months
girl you know you you have to enjoy it
[Music]